Well, there is a couple of ways to answer this question,
at least a couple, and I'm going to show you too.
The period is 2 seconds and we're talking about 7.5 seconds.
If a mass starts off up here, what are 2 seconds is complete one period;
two more, it's gone up here; two more, another period.
Okay, so far we've had 6 seconds elapsed.
What are 7 seconds that's half a period, and then another half a second,
well that's another half of what's left.
We'd wind up here. How else could we have solve this?
Remember that the amount of angle we go through in a certain amount of time is equal to ω  t.
Okay, I know that t is 7.5 seconds. How can I find ω?
Well, we have this relationship, T = 2π/ω, or rearrange, ω = 2π/T.
In this case, with a T of 2, ω is equal to just π radians/sec.
That means in each second, it's going to go π radians.
Well, 7π radians would be seven-halves of the circle.
Starting from here, that would be this angle, one-half, two, three, four, five, six, and seven,
but it was 7.5 seconds, so the extra π over 2 radians, and again that puts us right here.